BRET?
>> Bret: DAVID SPUNT AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
DAVID, THANK YOU.
ALSO BREAKING TONIGHT, GROWING
QUESTIONS ABOUT DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI'S CONDUCT REGARDING THOSE
EMAILS AND CONCERN IN THE DEBATE
OVER THE ORIGINS OF THE
CONTROVERSIES.
HIS CRITICS SAY HIS POSITIONS
HAVE BEEN INCONSISTENT AT BEST,
DECEPTIVE AT WORST.
BUT HE CONTINUES TO HAVE THE
FULL SUPPORT, PUBLICLY AT LEAST,
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY HAS DETAILS TONIGHT LIVE
FROM THE NORTH LAWN.
PETER?
>> Peter: GOOD EVENING BRET.
PRESIDENT BIDEN RAN ON HIRE
DR. FAUCI AND FIRE DONALD TRUMP.
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
COUNSEL COUNSEL HE WAS GIVEN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AS
THERE ARE CALLS FOR HIM TO BE
FIRED.
>> HOW MANY MORE TIMES DOES THIS
GUY NEED TO LIE BEFORE HE IS
OUSTED?
>> Peter: THIS IS SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO PROBLEM HISTORY OF MOVING
GOAL POSTS WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC HEALTH WITHHOLDING FACTS
THAT DON'T CONFORM WITH HIS OWN
NARRATIVE AND ISSUING
INAPPROPRIATE PERSONAL JUDGMENTS
THAT DISTORT THE TRUTH.
BUT FOR NOW, FAUCI'S JOB IS
SAFE.
>> JUST AS YOU MENTIONED
DR. FAUCI AGAIN, CAN YOU MENTION
ANY CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WOULD EVER FIRE HIM?
>> NO.
>> FAUCI'S INBOX EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC CONTAINED WORD THAT HIS
POSSIBLE COVID-19 WAS NOT
NATURAL BUT ENGINEERED ALTHOUGH
EXPERTS DON'T THINK THAT MEANS
FAUCI HAD BAD INTENTIONS.
>> EARLY ON THE EMAIL THAT'S
BEING FOCUSED ON IS SO-CALLED
SMOKING GUN IS EMAIL TONY
RECEIVED FROM SOME REALLY GOOD
SCIENTISTS THAT THEY FELT THIS
COULD HAVE BEEN ENGINEERED
PATHOGEN EARLY ON.
>> TWO EXPERTS WRITE IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" THE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE POINTS TO
THE CONCLUSION THAT THE VIRUS
WAS DEVELOPED IN A LABORATORY.
BUT THE CHINESE ARE WITHHOLDING
CRITICAL DATA FROM THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
>> SO THERE IS A REASON WHY,
AFTER A PLANE CRASHES, WE DO
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED.
AFTER -- IF WE DON'T LEARN THOSE
LESSONS, THERE ARE OTHER PLANES
THAT ARE IN THE AIR.
FOR ALL WE KNOW, THE NEXT
PANDEMIC IS JUST AROUND THE
CORNER.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN
DIPLOMATIC ABOUT THE LACK OF
COOPERATION SO FAR.
>> I HAVE PERSONALLY AND WE
COLLECTIVELY HAVE BEEN QUITE
VOCAL ABOUT OUR VIEW THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A SECOND ROUND TO
THIS INVESTIGATION.
THAT TRULY GETS TO THE HEART OF
THE MATTER, WHICH IS THE
ORIGINAL DATA AND ORIGINAL
INFORMATION THAT IS STILL BEING
WITHHELD BY CHINA.
AND OUR HOPE IS THAT IN THE
COMING MONTHS WE WILL SEE A
CREDIBLE INTERNATIONAL
INVESTIGATION PROGRESS INCLUDING
IN RESPECT TO THOSE ITEMS.
>> Peter: BUT THAT NIGHT BE
TOUGH.
>> Peter: CHINA HAS ALREADY SAID
THEY THINK THEIR PART IN AN
INTERNATIONAL INVESTIGATION IS
DONE.
WHY IS JAKE SULLIVAN STILL HERE
SAYING HE THINKS IT'S POSSIBLE
THEY ARE GOING TO PROVIDE THE
PRELIMINARY DATA.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK WE JUST
GIVE UP THAT EASILY.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE AND
PRESS IN COORDINATION WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
>> Peter: JUST OUTSIDE THE DOOR
TO THE WEST WING RIGHT NOW THE
SECRETARY GENERAL OF NATO IS
HOLDING COURT WITH REPORTERS
AFTER A LONG MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WE DIDN'T SEE PRESIDENT BIDEN ON
CAMERA AT ALL TODAY.
HE DID SEND HIS TOP DIPLOMAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TONY BLINKEN
TO CAPITOL HILL THOUGH.
AND TO TESTIFY IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS, I SHOULD SAY.
AND WHILE HE WAS DOING THAT
BLINKEN SAID HE CANNOT PUT A
PERCENTAGE ON THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT COVID MAY HAVE LEAKED OUT
OF A LAB IN CHINA.
BRET?
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, PETER, A BIT
OF A STIR THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
OR THE WHITE HOUSE DID NOT PUT
OUT A STATEMENT, A TWEET OR A
POST COMMEMORATING D-DAY.
WHY?
>> Peter: BRET, WHEN I ASKED AN
OFFICIAL HERE ABOUT THAT THEY
DIRECTED ME TO THE PRESIDENT'S
REMARKS LAST WEEK ON MEMORIAL
DAY WHERE HE DID MENTION THE
BEACHES OF NORMANDY WHILE
COMMEMORATING MEMORIAL DAY.
BUT I DID NOT GET A CLEAR ANSWER
FROM OR CLEAR EXPLANATION FROM
JEN PSAKI WHY IT IS THAT
PRESIDENTS BUSH, OBAMA, AND
TRUMP ALL COMMEMORATED D-DAY ON
D-DAY BUT BIDEN DIDN'T?
AND SHE SAYS THAT D-DAY IS
SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT HAS
TALKED A LOT ABOUT AND WE MAY
HEAR MORE ABOUT ININ COMING